so what should government or let's be
concrete what should this government
we're in the UK and presumably most
people here are from London the the
British government wants to be the
superpower of AI an AI superpower um and
is having an AI conference on AI safety
in November there's a big Focus here
what
should this government or indeed other
governments be doing concretely to
minimize the risks what should is there
stuff that should be banned now is there
rules that rules of the road that should
be put in place so so the first thing is
that governments have to build
technology you know we've we've got into
this habit of Outsourcing and
commissioning third parties to create
technology and I I think it's really
difficult to be able to control what you
don't understand and unless you build it
you don't deeply understand it so I
think that's just the first thing which
in itself is very controversial when I
propose that in government people sort
of throw up their hands and there's a
lack of will there's a lack of
self-confidence there's a lack of belief
that government can be a Creator and a
maker especially on the technology front
to do that I think the second thing is
that we have to have deeply Technical
and Engineering people as well as you
know technologists more generally in
cabinet positions and at the heads of
every government Department you know
it's it's pretty crazy to me that we
don't have a CTO a chief technology
officer in cabinet you know running our
big institutions
all of that is outsourced the challenge
is to be able to do that you just have
to pay close to private sector salaries
again another highly sensitive topic
that no one wants to talk about should
never earn more than the Prime Minister
you know to me this makes no sense how
can we have an open labor market where
on the one hand we're saying to people
you know go work for whoever you like
and on the one hand you know people are
being paid 10x and on the other we're
saying well take this huge sacrifice in
the name of Public Service the Practical
reality is that if that happens over
many decades the net effect is that you
have quality of one type over here and
another type over there and that's
really what we're facing we have to
confront that reality it's very
difficult for people to accept that we
should be paying super large salaries it
creates other issues around how we hold
you know those kinds of you know people
accountable given how much of the public
Pur they might be earning
Etc but fundamentally those two things
enable us third thing which is
governments have to take risks with
regulation there is a fear that
governments act too aggressively or too
experimentally and upset the big
companies and you know as someone who's
on the receiving end of this quite a lot
and have been in the past where I you
know mistakes have been made I still
think the right thing to do is to give
governments a break let them make
mistakes let them make investments that
don't work praise the experimental
governance structures have faith in the
political process participate encourage
it because otherwise you know there's
just this spiral of decline this sort of
lack of confidence that we can actually
do the right thing that we should do the
right thing and then that ultimately
leads to the self-fulfilling prophecy
much like with China and do you think
that your view is the exception in your
industry I mean The Stereotype is a
bunch of 30-year-old Tech Bros who you
know think the government is useless and
who are going to kind of change the
world with AI and you know WI going to
do this is that is that an accurate
stereotype are you the exception I mean
there is a you know should we worry
about the hubis of people in your
industry I I think you know we have
polarization everywhere so the The
Stereotype is probably true but the the
counter is that you know you know we we
can do it without technology and I think
that's totally wrong like technology is
an absolutely necessary but not
sufficient part of the process and I I
think that some people in silic like
Silicon Valley does have a tendency to
be much more techn libertarian there's
no question about that the government is
the problem that the objective is to
sort of eradicate the state and run it
completely independently and I'll be
honest there are some very very
influential very powerful people who
have that objective are building towards
that objective with both their companies
and their fortunes and you know I'm I'm
very skeptical of them and I you know
obviously I'm on the other side of that
and and that's what shapes a lot of the
public fear about this that you have a
bunch of hyper powerful people who are
shaping this um with without much with
kind of disdain for the the state and
the Democratic process two quick
questions for me which I know someone
would ask otherwise and then we're going
to audience questions the first one is
the whole question of the
singularity we can't have a conversation
about AI without the singularity will it
happen when will it happen I honestly
think it's a very unhelpful framing of
what's to come and people jump to this
framing because it's easy to point to
Terminator and sky
but it's it's almost like leaping to the
Moon before we've even invented the
transistor I mean it's a it's hundreds
of years away I it's really unhelpful
there are many practical near-term
operational capabilities that you can
predict just as I've tried to describe
and you can then use those to wrestle
with what are the consequences for the
nation state how does this change our
businesses what does this mean for our
governments so in general I don't make
those predictions I'm very skeptical
that the superintelligence framing is is
useful to us what about the other one
that you know backyard wannabe AI
commentators are always talking about
which is the odds of existential
catastrophe what are the odds that we
will wipe ourselves out with this again
I mean I think very very low I I really
think what's very low I I I think
infanty small such that it's not worth
putting in the reason I ask you that is
because I asked one of your um someone
somewhat similar to you what this was oh
very low they said and I said what's
very low oh about 5%
yeah so you think it's infinites netive
zero okay well that's a good place to
end all right we're going to open now to
your questions and questions um from the
online audience oh this is a good
question from Kitty hadock who asks what
will be the impact of all that computer
power on our carbon emissions or will AI
be able to enhance productivity so we
reduce carbon elsewhere yeah another hot
take on this very low and really
inconsequential the amount of carbon
that we spend on our data centers is
genuinely minuscule relatively speaking
secondly most of that happens in
completely renewable data centers Google
and Microsoft are both entirely 100%
renewable Google actually owns the
largest wind farm uh largest set of wind
farms in the world um one of the
projects that I worked on whilst I was
at Deep Mind was making the entire
windfarm fleet 20% more efficient so you
know right from the outset they have
been focused on this I'm not saying
there aren't other environmental
consequences like the use of you know
galenium and Cobalt in the actual chip
manufacturer and so on but I honestly
think that relative to the benefits that
we're seeing and with respect to the
absolute cost of carbon per unit of
computation it's very very small and and
just to follow up to that because an
argument I have often heard is that the
cost of electricity and the access to
power will be a constraint on the
development of these AIS and their
proliferation do you also think that's
not true no I I I I think that's not
true I mean I think that's not true I I
I think that some data centers will be
at the 100 megawatt scale which is maybe
a single digigit percentage of a small
City's electricity consumption but we're
talking about a very small number at the
100 megawatt scale I mean that really is
enormous nothing like that exists today
don't don't worry about the carbon
consequences of the actual AIS um from
the audience questions here yes lady
here in the second
row thank you um uh sheru from number of
Education
hello education companies that use AI um
my question to you is um if you think
about two industries say Healthcare and
education and you think about um the
applications that uh that that AI AI has
could you choose between the two which
you would hold um the most hope for and
um how should they be thinking about it
should they be thinking about procuring
it and how do you safely or procure it
well um or again as you said you could
produce it but some of those
organizations may not be in a position
to produce it anytime soon so if you're
a procurer um how do you do that well
and what are some of the Frameworks that
should be used for that yeah thank thank
you that's a great question I mean on
the I'm probably most excited in terms
of the immediate near-term impact about
education I mean these models are
already being used I think the primary
use case of chat GPT is in fact homework
help and people often think oh my kids
are you know copying and copy pasting
but actually if you actually watch the
way they're using these models and many
people use our models are high for
exactly this reason it's a
conversational interaction
much like an enthusiastic teacher might
speak to a child about the interest that
they have so the child or the Learner in
general gets to phrase the question in
exactly their style picking on exactly
the thing that they're interested in
asking the odd obscure poorly phrased
you know not complete picture type
question and of course the AI is
infinitely patient provides really
detailed mostly factual information I
mean it's not always perfect but it will
be perfect
and I think that's an unbelievable um
meritocratic gain for everybody I mean I
think we need to picture a world in 5
years time where the best education in
the world completely personalized
entirely factually accurate is available
to absolutely everybody who wants it on
the planet pretty much for
free which sounds amazing um how do you
go from where we are now to that uh to
that that world I think the beauty of
the um of these models is that they have
an inherent tendency to proliferate and
get smaller I mean that this is the
upside of proliferation they spread
because everybody wants access everybody
wants to integrate them you know there
are so many competing models now the
cost of um the the the the cost of
buying a model per word so if you're
building an app for example you'll go to
one of the three or four big model
creators and you pay per word that cost
has come down
70x since
January because we're all competing with
each other right so that means that you
can now take a regular app that you
might have been developing for you know
years in its current instantiation and
add a conversational widget in fact
we're doing this at The Economist with
the ecobot secret project underway
clearly not so secret
anymore thank
you
sorry and
you and you integrate you integrate the
conversational um element into your
existing workflow so you should be able
to ask any question in the style and the
theme of your brand about the specific
content that you have and it will be
like a widget it's like a plug and play
widget that you can put anywhere in the
app and that's what I mean about
proliferation obviously everybody finds
that useful and you'll be able to use
that tool as a in a low code or no code
environment it'll you know if you see
how the image generation models are
being integrated into Adobe today if
you're already a user of adobe you're
you're using the absolute Cutting Edge
AI models in a drag and drop way like no
training required you if you're building
a new website today it's Dragon drop you
just grab a little widget and plop it
over here and suddenly you have you know
a YouTube player with your video and
suddenly you have a conversational you
know interaction with a language model
that is conditioned over all your data
so I think it's important to wrap your
head around the idea that this is going
to be widely available to everybody
there isn't going to be an access issue
and the risk and harm comes from
mitigating the downsides of the Bad
actors who might use you you know use it
for nefarious purposes but the upsides
are
incredible let's get a go lots and lots
of hands let's get yes lady there but
I'm going to get one from online while
you get your microphone and the one from
online is a question from sa Paulo gosh
your audience is is going from from a
long way um Renee dealo Jr asks when you
say we will solve this and that who is
this we Humanity a good question
corporations the UN or Elon
Musk I definitely hope it's not Elon
Musk I think of it as the kind
of the community of researchers
inventors and creators there's this sort
of dialogue sometimes you see Snippets
of it on Twitter sometimes you see in
the research papers that academics
publish you know you see it in the blogs
and the products that big companies
produce there is this sort of unfolding
you know evolving mold of an ecosystem
which is referencing each other creating
and evolving and so when I say we I
certainly don't mean me at inflection um
my current company I just mean the the
the ecosystem of humanity like we're
we're trending collectively in a
direction of invention and creation just
one tiny does that ecosystem include
Chinese
scientists so 10 years ago Chinese
scientists were not really part of the
conversation they weren't really very
relevant over the last 10 years they
have launched onto the scene producing
very high quality research creative
research you know the old stereotype was
that they can only copy and steal again
I think a demonization partly by Elon
Musk actually who was a big proponent of
this idea that they were just robbing
our intellectual property and there was
some of that but largely they were just
as creative as us and they wanted to get
access to these tools to build their own
businesses and and provide new products
and services for their own citizens for
the same reason as we do and so if you
start from that assumption then of
course they're participating in this
ecosystem of course they're creating
incredible models you know they have
their own constraints with respect to
censorship and that has slowed them down
by a little bit but they're actually not
going to be that far behind now I mean
there are some issues with the export
controls and they don't have access to
Cutting Edge models but I don't think
that's going to hold them back for very
long interesting gu go ahead thanks this
is excellent uh my question is about AI
ideas and the people needed to think of
them and if you take someone like Steve
Jobs for instance you had very specific
person very specific interests and
skills and talent to be able to develop
not only technology but the brand and a
point of view on the world that came
with that do you think AI would be
capable of coming up let's say with the
the version of the Apple idea now will
it be in the future or will it simply be
a machination of past
information so I think people have often
characterized these AIS as regurgitating
their training data right uh or
reproducing whatever they have seen
previously and I think that's a kind of
misunderstanding of what they do they're
almost always doing interpolation the
thing I described earlier is predicting
the space between two ideas they're
saying let me mash together these two
concepts just like the dog and the
yellow spots and whatever or take your
pick of any com combination and that's
creativity you know fundamentally when I
invent something I'm really being
inspired by a huge range of different
experiences and ideas and I'm using
those to then produce a novel prediction
or generation at any given moment and
I'm testing it out and seeing if it's
you know useful or if it makes sense or
if it catches on and then it has life of
its own and it's sort of independent of
me so I think for the next couple of
decades these AIS are going to Aid the
human in that process of creation and
invention and Discovery they're not
going to wander off and have their own
agency and do their own thing I mean
it's just not just not possible the
capabilities just aren't there and won't
be there in the near term to do that
right and so I think it's going to be
the human AI combo for a good time to
come that does the creation more brist
suppos to be exactly it's more of the
assistant exactly the brilliant
assistant um right let's go further back
yes gentlemen there for Rose back um Are
you seriously trying to suggest that the
um
no that the AI companies are able to
self-regulate and didn't the banks prove
that that is an impossible concept oh
the banks are highly highly regulated
and so not just by themselves but look
I'm absolutely not proposing
self-regulation I mean if if that came
across then I apologize I'm wrong I mean
in the in the book I really don't say
that I go to Great Lengths to say that
independent external technical expertise
is required to do governance properly I
think the Practical challenge as you
know zany pushed back on me earlier
today when we were talking with youal is
where are these competent Regulators who
get the technical aspects where is this
Democratic process that gives us
confidence that we can appoint people to
to conduct that kind of of oversight so
I think there's there's some pessimism
that they're capable of doing that that
should not mean that we sit around and
do nothing in the process um you know
for example we I visited President Biden
six weeks ago now at the White House
with the other six AI companies
Microsoft meta Google deepmind etc etc
and we signed up to voluntary
commitments that were that are precursor
to regulation which the White House
designed because they realized they
can't pass new primary regul anytime
soon but the voluntary commitments are
very material they we basically have
said publicly we expose our models to
expert independent scrutiny to Red Team
or stress test find weaknesses in our
own models once we identify those
weaknesses we share them with each other
and we share them publicly so in you
know transparency in you know the open
light of day and we know that that
framework the voluntary commitments are
a precursor to an executive order which
is coming from the president sometime in
the next few months they're also the
basis for the Prime Minister Rishi sunak
AI Summit in November in in in Bletchley
Park where you know many world leaders
and all the big tech companies are
coming and those voluntary commitments
are going to form the basis of the
discussions for what becomes binding not
just in the UK but hopefully worldwide
so I'm totally with you that we're not
going for a self-regulatory approach but
you don't you don't think there's a
conflict of interest well I I mean I I
definitely a conflict of interest of
course there's a conflict of interest I
mean we are a profitable a for-profit
company in fact I'm a public benefit
Corporation so I think it's kind of an
important clarification um it's a new
type of company closer to a borp um
which is a hybrid for-profit nonprofit
Mission it means that our directors have
a legal obligation to factor in the
impact of our activities on The Wider
World both the environment and people
materially affected by what we do who
aren't just our customers and that
doesn't solve all the issues with
for-profit businesses and the conflict
that you described but it's a first step
in the right direction and I I believe
that that's how change happens taking
small steps in the right
direction let's take a question from
over there yes gentleman quite near the
back with the white T-shirt y right
there hello yeah okay my question to you
as an electronics engineer is should we
now focus on the hardware part of it
considering there's a monopoly going on
and the concentration of chips to a
certain country the harder part of it is
raising a very big question we saw it in
co uh things are really bad when
Hardware Supply goes down so is this a
great time to focus on Hardware
considering we are good with software
part for now that that's a great
question I mean we didn't really talk
about that too much here but you know
just just for everyone's benefit these
AI models are trained on gpus Graphics
processing units so chips that were
previously used for G gaming for
representing Graphics in computers and
we take each one of these chips and we
daisy chain them together thousands and
thousands of times we have a computer at
inflection which is the size of four
football pitches and has 25,000 of these
chips daisy chain together an enormous
cluster it cost about a billion and a
half dollars now all of these chips are
manufactured by one company NVIDIA who
I'm sure people will have heard have
seen their share price go up by
350% since January their chips are
manufactured entirely in one Factory
called
tsmc Taiwan semiconductor Manufacturing
corporation which is obviously in Taiwan
the key component of their chips of
their fabrication facility are
manufactured by one company called asml
a Dutch company so the supply chain is I
mean we can talk about how this happened
over 30 years but extremely narrow there
really are no competing providers that
are material at any of those three
stages as a result the good news is that
that means that there are choke points
that can be used by Regulators to
monitor who has access to the critical
chips that enable the training of the
models and of course restrict access to
certain people so I think I Loosely
alluded to the export controls minute
ago which is a new piece of legislation
or a rule that the US Administration
imposed on China um last year which
prevents China anyone in China any
manufacturer in China from getting
access to the latest version of these
chips which means that they won't be
able to train the gbt 5 level model a
number of people have referred to this
as a declaration of economic war on
China and so you know I think I think
that we have to be very cognizant of
that denying them access to that is
likely to deliver a significant
Counterattack on you know the West we
are hugely dependent on their supply
chain in many many respects so yeah
chips are absolutely at the heart of
this both in good and bad ways so if
you're focused on a chip company it's a
big bet it takes a long time to mature
but it has the potential to be the
critical component here just a followup
question yes uh do you think that that
open- Source Hardware will help in
creating a better setup right now
considering very few companies are
focusing on creating the hardware and
all of them are completely non uh
completely for profit so something like
Open Source Hardware focusing more
helping will it help us create a better
computers creating better models with
less power yeah so I I think open-
Source Hardware is a serious effort and
just to clarify I mean open source
elements of Hardware design are used in
many many areas so open ran for example
is a hardware designed for 5G Ms which
ensures they're interoperable it means
that the software that runs your
telephone networks actually can run on
any type of Hardware because the
interface is standardized which is a
great thing for competition there isn't
a lock in between Hardware the builder
of the masts and the software the people
who run the operating system that sits
on top of that the downside of it is
that it has tended to be a bit more
flaky than the fully integrated side of
things so I think you should be
wide-eyed about it it isn't going to be
the Panacea to solve all of our problems
anytime soon let's take another question
there yes lady in the fourth
row hi thank you both um I'm javah Rari
I lead digital regulation work at Tech
UK which is the uh digital Tech trade
body in the UK over a thousand members
um ranging from Big Tech Deep Mind
Google Mata all the way through to cyber
security providers smes um many of our
members are harnessing the really
positive impacts of synthetic media um
but many are becoming increasingly
concerned with the rising malicious use
of deep fakes so everything from Revenge
pornography undermining digital ID
verification um fraud which is a big one
um in your opinion what should companies
do now to address the rising um kind of
problem of of deep fakes I know you
mentioned um voluntary Charters which we
already do with things like fraud um but
what should we do now yeah it's a great
question I mean I I think the first
thing to say is that political parties
and political campaigns shouldn't be
allowed to use AI generators for their
content I think we should just start by
taking that off the table that's a
precautionary principle there
potentially some downsides to that but
it feels like a safer and sensible thing
to do right the second thing to say is
that we shouldn't allow the big Tech
platforms so Facebook or Twitter or or
anywhere where there's a broadcast of
information to have digital people
counterfeit digital people right so if
you you know have a handle zany on
Twitter for example only zany should be
allowed to represent as zany on Twitter
I shouldn't be able to come along create
a perfect synthetic fake of zany and
have that you know imitate her language
now I think that's a reasonably
straightforward sensible thing that all
the big Tech platforms will commit to
it's doesn't address other platforms
right outside of you know the big big
providers and those tools and techniques
are going to be widely available again
it's a proliferation question it's going
to be really difficult to say to
somebody well you know you're using
synthetic media to generate a new
product design or a new fashion outfit
or all these other good uses um you're
not allowed to have it because there's a
risk that you're going to be able to
generate some you know deep fake I think
we should also be like wide-eyed about
how how quickly we adjust to the risks
you know like back in you know 20 odd
years ago people were like well we'll
never be able to do Financial
transactions on the internet because
there's so much fraud right we're going
to be inundated with fraudulent activity
we do tens of trillions of dollars of
transactions has completely transformed
our world and we have a minuscule amount
of Fraud and it's a constant back and
forth you know likewise with Spam
detection right we we everyone thought
we're going to be inundated with SC spam
we're going to produce all this
automated content increasingly the next
threat is that um you know older people
are being tricked by AIS that you know
can imitate the voice of say your
daughter or child who you know might be
asking you for a loan or something
there's this con man scam type thing
which is now a little like more more
possible and more capable of course
that's a new Threat Vector that causes
real harm on the flip side spreading
knowledge and information about it
there's a very very simple defense which
is just to say you know never provide
access you know to my account over the
phone right I'll never you know call you
out of the blue asking for that so we
adjust we adapt and it you know it
doesn't mean that we can eliminate all
of the harms but it means that like net
net we just have to be more resilient
and more focused on
adaptation